alors ça y est c'est arrivé rené coty a
pété un câble il ya six mois il se
prenait pour mitterrand maintenant il se
prend pour le maréchal rommel
alors un type de la manif de dimanche
passé l'a comparé à hitler bon c'est pas
c'est pas complètement faux le maïs est
quoi c'est une pologne déshydraté donc
alors historiquement la seule expédition
de l'armée française dans le désert
c'était napoléon vias qu'au total
évidemment alors voir hollande réussir
là où napoléon échoué c'est à peu près
aussi probable que découvrir ben laden
planqué dans la grotte de lourdes
alors il a appelé l'opération militaire
l'opération serval alors c'est un félin
c'est un petit félin qui a la
particularité de pisser 30 fois en une
heure pour marquer son territoire
comme quoi d'être intronisé sous la
pluie ça vous marque une présidence
alors évidemment branle bas de combat le
ministre de la défense annonce des raids
aériens sur le mali ah bon et un truc à
bombarder la bavure
enfin je ne sais pas tu montre une photo
du mali avant les bombardements un
général de la deuxième guerre mondiale
ils te répondent tient bon travail quoi
passer toute la démesure française est
là quoi poursuivre des pick-up avec des
mirage et des rafales
alors de nombreux français se posent des
questions la première est ce que c'est
stratégique d'envoyer des hommes au mali
ah bah évidemment le mali ces stratégies
crise et on peut pas faire partie des
grandes puissances mondiales si on
contrôle pas de la production de manioc
et de patates douces c'est
évident or la france a envoyé 1700
hommes est-ce que c'est suffisant
faisons un calcul rapide sachant qu'il
faut une équipe de 32 policiers du raid
pour faire sortir de sa salle de bains à
un type armé de deux colts
convient en foot il pour affronter 6000
djihadistes frottant à l'air libre alors
je fais le calcul six mille fois trop
oms a fait 180 mille hommes au mali
combien la france on at elle envoyé
bon alors notre question c'est combien
de temps va durer l'opération continuons
les calculs sachant qu'il a fallu trente
heures aux policiers du raid pour
déloger momo de son hammam privatif
pour 6000 hommes cela fait donc trente
heures fois 6000 hommes ce qui nous
donne deux cent quarante mille jours
donc 657 en
hollande où l'optimisme
alors bon attention on n'est pas les
seuls à on a des renforts les belges
envoie 75 soldats mais pas au front on
se sait pas c'est pour le soutien moral
je vois le truc tu vois ils viendront
avec des banderoles allez les bleus
est bon en face les mecs cd sérieux quoi
c'est ils disent qu'ils vont taper le
coeur de la france on va encore mal
dormir à tulle
façon aussi prend très mal avec les
islamistes pour des fanatiques faut
envoyer des fanatiques sais pas ce qu'il
leur faudrait c'est pas des légionnaires
mais les mecs de civitas
en tout cas l'otage occidental à la cote
pour les islamistes les otages
catholique se trouve peut-être de
religion mais en termes de valeur
marchande c'est du bien de luxe au sahel
l'otage occidentale c'est comme
l'immobilier à paris se démode pas c'est
valeurs sûres
alors évidemment une guerre c'est aussi
des familles déchirées et moi j'ai une
pensée émue pour toutes les femmes des
djihadistes rester derrière la ligne de
front se doit pas être évident être une
femme de djihadistes c'est la nana qui
reçoit une lettre de son mec mon amour
je t'aime je pense à toi ps pourquoi tu
lis ces mots un pur chienne
100 en ce moment la france elle a un
truc avec les pays en ali quoi somalie
mali fâcherait l'italie je me méfierais
un peu
on dit que l'opération est un fiasco en
somalie balle c'est faux c'est à dire
plus d'otages français s'est enfin plus
vivants
réussite par ici façon au fond moi force
de faire ces bêtises hollande au mali
mamadou quoi s'est
il en faut pour tout le monde
société alors la semaine passée a eu
cette manif je ne sais plus très bien
contre pour job en or bertrand delanoë
réclament 100 mille euros pour les
dégâts je suppose que lors de la
prochaine manifestation pro mariage gay
et demanderont les numéros de téléphone
des manifestants
[Applaudissements]
moi j'ai moi j'ai été extrêmement choqué
par certains slogans vraiment j'ai zéro
maman c'est déprimant on voit qu'ils
connaissent pas ma mère
alors ils couinent parce qu'ils sont pas
entendus ça c'est vraiment des bleus en
france et encore des naïfs qui pensent
qu'on peut bloquer le pays sans bosser à
la sncf
tu m'étonnes que hollande y résiste à la
pression de la rue dur c'est pas très
dur de résister à une manif de droite
une manif de gauche s'ils sont pas
entendus il bloque les métros là les
gens y vont bloquer quoi ils vont
bloquer quoi l'accès à la maison du
chocolat et un petit bateau c'est sa
façon on mélange tout entre le mariage
l'adoption la pma de façon je me pose
moi mais je me suis demandé à quoi
est-ce qu'on reconnaît un enfant né sous
pma et c'est le mec qui crie maman quand
ils voient une pipette
et qui fait une dépression quand il fait
des tp de chimie là il peut plus passer
bon moi personnellement moi j'aimerais
vraiment être un enfant adopté quoi en
couchant avec des femmes 45 ans j'aurais
au moins l'espoir que l'une d'entre
elles soit ma mère
en a pour tous les goûts
façon moi et commence à me saouler que
leur histoire de mariage toi même si
c'est mais légitime c'est vraiment c'est
à dire la réforme c'est moi je suis sûr
que le rêve de rimbaud et verlaine
c'était de s'acheter un lob dans le
marais et de louer le ventre de george
sand pour y faire fructifier marcel
ya des évidences comme ça ça saute aux
yeux c'est implacable après je comprends
que l'église soit contre le mariage gay
c'est normal c'est ce qui gêne l'église
c'est pas l'amour entre deux hommes mais
c'est que vu les orifices concernés dans
un couple homo il est impossible de
rester vierge jusqu'au mariage
[Applaudissements]
reproché à l'église d'être contraintes
sont naïves quand je veux dire je vois
bien moi benoît c est ce qui va bouger
son dogme pour faire plaisir à la gay
pride faut franchement faut se réveiller
quoi benoît 16 qui est allé jusqu'à
citer le grand rabbin bernheim pour
appuyer ses propos c'est étonnant c'est
tendance à c'est peut-être la première
fois qu'un pape cite un juif en dehors
d'une préfecture de police
économie alors la période des soldes
continuent chez renault on va licencier
sept mille cinq cents ouvriers
franchement quand on voit la gueule de
leur voiture ferait mieux de licencier
les mecs qui les dessine
[Applaudissements]
moi chaque fois que je vois une renault
je me dis que les types qui les dessine
sont des anciens de chez playmobil
façon les futurs concessionnaires se
sera joué club à mon avis dans combien
de temps le sport armstrong s'est dopé
je vois vraiment pas où est le problème
je dire si tout le monde se dope à la
fin c'est quand même le meilleur qui
gagne
fait divers alors c'est un mec qui reste
est mort pendant 36 heures dans les
toilettes d'un hôpital sans être
découvert alors peut-être que la lutte
contre les maladies nosocomiales ça
serait déjà de faire venir une femme de
ménage plus d'une fois par semaine
sinon bonne nouvelle marseille capitale
européenne de la culture
c'est la vanne
alors elle est pas belle la vie les
corrections de ne rien rater de 1h10
tube abonnez vous il m'était impossible
eux